they're among the most persecuted people
in the world according to human rights
organizations but you probably haven't
heard much about them Myanmar's ruhango
they're stateless they're displaced and
they're quite possibly facing a genocide
mas gang rapes killings including of
babies and young children
Myanmar's Muslim ethnic minority has
faced persecution for decades and that
persecution has only gotten worse since
Myanmar's transition from Ahuja to a
democracy hey guys I'm Sunna
this is AJ plus and this Sunday I want
to talk about who they were hanging out
are and how they became among the most
persecuted people in the world
[Music]
the hing are a Muslim minority in the
Buddhist majority country of Myanmar
which was previously known as Burma
until a military junta changed the name
in 1989 they're one of more than a
hundred ethnic groups in the country
based in the western state over kind the
story of these 1.1 million people begins
with Myanmar's independence from British
colonial rule in 1948 now the British
colonial period in present-day Myanmar
was pretty brutal from 1824 to 1885
there were three anglo-burmese wars
throughout these wars the British would
take more and more land from the Burmese
Kingdom eventually the British took all
of it and made it into a province of
their biggest colony India now the
British directly ruled over Burma and
they did it by getting rid of two vital
institutions in Burmese society the
monarchy and the marriage between
religion and the state and this was a
big deal the separation of religion and
state had a huge impact on Buddhist
monks who were lied on the monarchy for
support that and the disrespect shown by
the British towards Burmese culture and
Buddhist tradition pushed monks to be at
the forefront of the movement for
independence that had begun to take
shape by the early 1900s and the men
responsible for actually creating the
Burmese independence movement was Major
General Aung Sun he by the way is the
father of present-day Myanmar's de facto
civilian leader Aung San su Chi who's a
former political prisoner and Nobel
Peace Prize winner remember her name
because she's pretty relevant to the
story of the Rohingya as I'll discuss in
a bit
now after independence in 1948 the union
of Burma as it was called had a
democratic government but a military
coup in 1962 would bring over a decade
of
to an end the military overthrew the
democratically elected government and
instituted who into a rule that would
last until 2011 now where do the rahaga
fit into all of this well the government
and much of the country's population
considered there were hanging up
migrants or Bengalis they believe the
group either migrated illegally from
Bangladesh or came as refugees during
the 1971 Bangladesh war for independence
the thing is many historians believe
there were hinga have been living in the
Rakhine State since the 15th century and
the wardro hinga itself means those of
were hung were hung is the early Muslim
name of Eric on which is now known as a
reclined state but they're still not
considered citizens when the union of
Burma became independent in 1948 it
instituted an exclusionary definition of
citizenship the country's constitution
said only quote indigenous races of the
land could be considered citizens and
while the country is home to 135
different legally recognized ethnicity
sarena have never been and still aren't
one of them and the 1982 Myanmar
Nationality Act made sure that the were
hanging out wouldn't become citizens
human rights groups and even the United
Nations protested the Act which
instituted three categories of citizens
it was specifically designed to deny
there were hanging US citizenship so
Myanmar says there were hanging aren't
citizens and are actually from
Bangladesh but Bangladesh doesn't
recognize a group either leaving there
were hanger without a country as Human
Rights Watch Amnesty International the
United Nations and others have noted
through Hingis statelessness has denied
them the most basic rights and
protections their movement is restricted
violence against them is treated with
impunity if not promoted and their homes
and villages are often raised or
attacked now in recent years the group's
vulnerability to mob and state violence
has caught the attention of the
international community in 2011 military
rule in Myanmar came to an official end
as the country began to make political
and economic reforms towards a
democratic system part of those reforms
included undoing certain censorship laws
and allowing foreign journalists into
the country with fewer restrictions that
meant more coverage more access there
were also hopes that wither reforms
significant changes would come to
Myanmar's abuse of not only political
power but human rights but since the
political reforms the situation for the
Raheja has only worsened there's a lot
of evidence that the government and
government backed Buddhist groups
engaged in ethnic cleansing and even
genocide in 2012 some of the worst
violence against there were hinga and
other Muslims broke out after the rape
and murder of a buddhist woman by three
Muslim men the violence led to nearly
280 dead as Buddhist mobs around through
her kind to push the Raheja
out of the state eventually about a
hundred and twenty-five thousand were
hinga and other Muslims were forcibly
displaced Human Rights Watch accused the
government of ethnically cleansing
Muslims that it orchestrated mob
violence against them and that it quote
destroyed mosque conducted violent mass
arrests and blocked aid to displace
Muslims the report also accused the
government of allowing mobs to kill
civilians and of burying the dead in
mass graves then in 2015 the al jazeera
investigative unit worked with a gale
law schools Lowenstein Clinic in an
investigation into whether Myanmar
government was in fact committing
genocide against our ohanga
the eight month investigation determined
that there was in fact enough evidence
to say yes the government was engaged in
a genocide and violence against our
hanga by the way hasn't stopped despite
more and more international attention
and pressure on Myanmar a February 2017
report released by the United Nations
outlined the sort of quote devastating
cruelty faced by the rahaga since
October 9 2016 when another bout of
sectarian violence erupted in our kind
mas gang rapes killings including of
babies and young children brutal
beatings disappearances and other
serious human rights violations by
Myanmar security forces in a sealed off
area north of moong dal in northern rock
Hinde state have been detailed in the
report that our team has put together as
a result tens of thousands of her hanga
have fled Myanmar fled the violence and
fled the crushing 78% poverty rate that
devastates our kind between 2012 and now
almost 170,000 row heungguk are believed
to have fled to neighboring Bangladesh
or taken to the water being smuggled
into countries like Thailand and
Malaysia now there was a belief for a
little while that former political
prisoner and leader of the Democratic
opposition ansan SUCI would be a sort of
light from Myanmar there was hope that
she would take the same force she
brought to resist ohonta and push
myanmar towards major Democratic changes
but the icon for the fight for
democratic
has not only remained virtually silent
on the row hanga she has even restricted
UN access to investigate the conditions
they live in and any allegations of
ethnic cleansing and genocide so it
seems for now despite more and more
international attention being paid to
the plight of the row hinga there's
actually very little hope for any end to
it so one of the reasons why we decided
to do this story on the Roja is because
here at aj+ we really do believe in
covering underreported stories and
underreported communities did you guys
know about there were Hingham and what
are some other underreported communities
that you think we should cover let us
know in the comments and don't forget to
Like share and subscribe and tune in
next Sunday when we come at you with
another great video